uh hi everyone I'm Sam gross and I'm
talking here to talk about my project
that I've been working on for the past
few years to let python run
multi-threaded programs without the
global interpreter lock
I'd like to start with a bit of
background on multi-threading and
Python's Global interpreter lock
multi-threading using multiple threads
allows an individual program to perform
multiple tasks at the same time threads
are useful for two related reasons
first threads can exploit the
parallelism available in multiprocessor
and multi-core computers
threads can run on separate cores so a
program that can divide its work into
multiple tasks executed by separate
threads can run faster on a multi-core
computer than if it used a single thread
the second reason is that threads can be
useful for structuring concurrency even
on a single processor system
threads might be used to handle multiple
requests in a network server
to overlap I O with computation or to
perform long-running tasks in a
graphical application while keeping the
user interface responsive
threads aren't the only way to structure
concurrency for example modern python
includes the async i o package
to structure concurrent asynchronous
code
but this project is mostly focused on
the first reason we want python to be
able to take advantage of the
parallelism available in multi-core
computers by making multi-threaded code
run more efficiently
one of the big obstacles to efficiency
is that the global interpreter lock or
Gill ensures that only one thread can
run python code at a time
when python was first publicly released
in 1991 it didn't support threads or
have a global interpreter lock
support for Threads was added about year
a year later in 1992 together with the
Gill
for context the 1990s saw a number of
operating systems add better support for
threading and support for computers with
multiple processors
I think there's an interesting analogy
between the introduction of threads in
Python and multi-processor support in
some of these operating systems at least
in the cases of Linux and FreeBSD
support for multiple processors was
accompanied by the introduction of
global locks the big kernel lock in
Linux and a lot called Giant in FreeBSD
in the original implementation the big
kernel lock ensured that only a single
thread could enter the kernel at a time
somewhat similar to the way the Python's
Global interpreter locked ensures that
only a single thread can run python code
at a time
over time the uses of the big kernel
lock were gradually replaced by fine
grain locking and other techniques to
improve scalability
the big kernel lock was completely
removed from Linux in 2011.
from a technical perspective the global
interpreter lock makes a lot make made
sense for a few reasons
first it's simple to implement it
doesn't require a lot of code
second the global interpreter lock is
really efficient for single threaded
code the lock is only rarely touched so
it doesn't substantially affect
performance if you only use one one
thread
third the global interpreter lock avoids
a lot of the potential deadlocking
hazards of using multiple fine grain
locks in particular the Locking
discipline for the Gill is pretty
straightforward you need to acquire the
Gill once before calling into python
code and you should release the Gill
before calling an operation that might
block the thread
finally the global interpreter lock
still allows for some parallelism
C extensions can release the lock around
long-running pieces of code that don't
access python objects
we're now about 30 years after the
introduction of threads to Python and as
Larry mentioned the computer hardware
landscape has changed multi-core
processors are in desktops laptops
servers smartphones and today I learned
they're in glasses as well in server
environments it's come to see computers
with dozens of CPU cores or more
especially as the core counts increase
it's difficult to take advantage of
multi-core parallelism from python due
to the Gill
even with the guild there are a number
of ways to paralyze python programs
today but they all have substantial
limitations first in C API extensions
you can paralyze operations internally
in a way that's invisible to python for
example scikit-learn uses openmp to
paralyze its k-means operation when you
call the scikit-learn's K means K means
function from python scikit-learn
distributes the work to a number of
threads Waits For Those threads to
finish and aggregate Aggregates the
results and returns back to python this
works well when individual operations
are large enough to be efficiently
paralyzed but not when there are a lot
of small steps a lot of scientific
Computing libraries like scikit-learn
pytorch and some versions of numpy and
scipy use this technique
second Capi extensions can release the
global interpreter lock around
long-running operations so that multiple
operations can overlap the previously
mentioned scientific Computing libraries
do this but it usually doesn't scale
well beyond a few cores because
contention on the Gill quickly becomes
an issue
you can also use multiple processes
including through Python's
multi-processing Library processes are
like a heavyweight version of threads
the main challenge with processes is
that communication between processes is
usually more expensive and more
difficult than communicating between
threads I'm going to expand on this
point
with processes objects need to be
serialized to be sent from one process
to another you can't share python
objects directly like you can between
threads
this is a performance issue because
serialization is expensive
and requires making extra copies it can
also lead to usability issues because
not all objects support serialization
additionally many CNC plus libraries you
might want to use from python don't work
well across processes even if the
library support multiple threads
some libraries have opaque data
structures that might be difficult or
impossible to share between processes
removing the global interpreter law is a
challenge because besides the actual
removal of the lock you have to make
python safe to run with multiple threads
you have to address things like
reference scouting python primarily
manages memory by keeping track of the
number of references to each object and
the current implementation isn't thread
safe without the Gill
you also have to figure out how to
handle concurrent accesses to Python's
collections
things like dictionaries lists and sets
once you remove the Gill unless you've
made other changes concurrent
modifications to things like
dictionaries would crash The Interpreter
there are a lot of other internal
components
in the python interpreter that need to
be made thread safe many of these are
easy to fix and only require small
changes but other require more
substantial changes some of the specific
internals I want to talk about today are
Python's built-in memory allocator and
the cyclic garbage collector
finally all these changes need to be
made while keeping good single threaded
performance and while allowing for
efficient multi-threaded scaling
this project isn't the first attempt to
remove Python's Global interpreter lock
I'm aware of three previous attempts in
C python
the first was in 1996 when Greg Stein
released his free threading patch the
patch used Atomic reference counting on
Windows and a global reference count
block on Linux list and dictionary
accesses were protected by mutexes parts
of the patch were actually adopted
Upstream in particular it introduced a
pi thread State structure and correct
per threaded exception handling both of
which live on in Python today
the second attempt I know of was python
safe thread by Adam Olson in 2007. Adam
pursued an interesting design most
objects were owned by a single thread
which could use normal reference
counting operations if another thread
needed to modify the object's reference
count it would have to pause and wait
for the owning thread to give up
ownership
the implementation also had restrictions
on sharing objects between threads
you could share immutable objects like
numbers and strings and some special
objects like a new shared dictionary
type trying to share it other Mutual
excuse me trying to share other mutable
objects like a regular dictionary or
List would raise an exception
the most recent attempt to remove the
Gill from C python is Larry Hastings
galactomy which started around
2016-16 the galectomy used Atomic
reference counting for objects and later
versions experimented with buffered
reference counting to improve
performance the implementation used
locks to protect accesses to lists and
dictionaries the galectomy was the
effort that had the most influence on
this project I had seen Larry's picon
talks on the glectomy where he described
parts of the implementation and the
Performance challenges
I think the biggest takeaway from these
previous efforts is the recurring
challenges due to reference counting
both in how it affects single thread
performance and efficient scaling
reference counting is by no means the
only issue you have to address when
removing the Gill but it's essentially
the first problem you have to solve
because the performance impact is so
large
a number of people have come to the
conclusion that reference counting is
the biggest obstacle to moving the Gill
and that we should ditch reference
counting and replace it with a tracing
garbage collector so why not ditch
reference Counting
the primary reason is that to getting
rid of reference counting would make it
much harder to get a reasonable degree
of compatibility with existing Capi
extensions
I think the effort to get a reasonable
degree of compatibility would probably
be bigger than just directly dealing
with the issues that reference counting
poses
the most straightforward way to make
reference counting threads safe is to
use Atomic operations
the problem with this strategy is that
Atomic instructions are slower to
execute than their non-atomic
counterparts for example if you modify
python to use Atomic reference counting
and run the pi performance Benchmark
Suite the benchmarks take on average
about 60 percent longer to run
this chart shows the Slowdown of using
Atomic reference counting in each
Benchmark in the pi performance Suite
there's big variants in individual
Benchmark performance so don't treat the
60 number as particularly precise
a few benchmarks aren't affected by the
reference counting change While others
take more than twice as long to run
biased reference counting is an
algorithm created to address the
overhead of atomic reference Counting it
was created by jihotoi Thomas schul and
Joseph Torres at the University of
Illinois at Urbana-Champaign and
published in 2018
it's based on the observation that most
objects are only accessed by a single
thread even in a multi-threaded
environment
their version was implemented in Swift
but the same technique can be applied to
python
bias reference counting works by
splitting the reference count field into
two parts
as well as storing the threat of the ID
of the thread that created the object
the first part of the reference count
field stores the local reference count
the thread that created the object uses
plain non-atomic operations to modify
that local reference count field
the second field stores the shared
reference count
other threads modify the shared field
using Atomic
Atomic instructions the true reference
count is the sum of these two fields
because most objects are only accessed
by one thread the technique avoids most
Atomic operations while still
maintaining thread safety
here's a basic implementation of
incrementing the reference count using
biased referencing bias reference
counting the algorithm checks if the
object's thread ID matches the current
thread ID if they match the algorithm
increments the local reference count
field using normal non-atomic increments
otherwise the algorithm increments the
shared field using an atomic operation
this is faster than just using an atomic
reference counting because at least on
current Hardware the extra comparison to
check the thread ID is cheaper than the
cost of an atomic increment
this technique has some similarity to
the um to the strategy used by Adam
Olson in the python safe thread project
both associate a python object with the
thread that creates it and that thread
uses fast non-atomic operations
however biased reference counting avoids
the blocking operation present in Python
safe thread where a different thread
accesses the object it has to wait for
the original thread to give up ownership
here's an updated version of the
previous chart Atomic reference counting
overhead is still shown in blue those
are the same results as before
bias reference counting is in green the
overhead of biased reference counting is
much less than the overhead of atomic
reference counting although it still has
some extra overhead compared to the
regular non-thread safe reference
counting that's currently implemented in
Python
using python39 as a base bias reference
counting is about 10 percent slower on
average across the pi performance
benchmarks compared to that 60 slowdown
we saw with atomic reference Counting
while biased reference counting does a
pretty good job of reducing the
execution overhead of atomic reference
counting it doesn't address the
scalability scalability issues when
multiple threads frequently modify the
reference count of the same object
to expand on this I'm going to make some
generalizations about how memory
operations scale on modern computer
systems
this table is divided in columns between
operations that are read only and
operations that modify memory the rows
are divided into private accesses that's
memory that's accessed only by a single
core and shared Access Memory that's
access accessed by multiple cores the
check marks indicate if the operations
scale well as the number of cores
increase
the first thing to notice is that
read-only accesses scale well with lots
of course memory reads from multiple
cores both to the same location scales
well as well as reads to different
locations the same data can exist in the
cache of multiple CPU cores as long as
the data isn't modified
the second thing I'd like to point out
is that right operations scale well if
the data is private
in other words multiple CPU cores
performing right operations scale well
as long as they're to different memory
addresses or more accurately to
different cache lines this includes
Atomic operations things like Atomic
increment and decrement are slower than
their non-atomic counterparts but both
Atomic and non-atomic operations scale
well if the data is private
finally concurrent modifications to
share data doesn't scale well so for
example lots of threads concurrently
modifying the reference count of the
same object won't scale well on
multi-core machines
this is relevant for python because
there are some objects that are
necessarily shared between threads and
they're frequently accessed
for example the constants none true
false some small integers and some other
objects are shared by all threads in a
Python program
like other python objects they're also
reference counted even though they can
never be collected during the lifetime
of the program
absent other changes reference counting
on these objects would be a bottleneck
for multi-threaded programs once you
remove the Gill
the fix is to skip reference counting in
these objects the objects are marked as
Immortal using a bit in the reference
count field
the reference counting code is changed
to be a no-op if the immortal bit is set
and the objects are kept alive for the
duration of the program
this works well because things like none
true and false already stay alive for
the lifetime of a Python program
Immortal objects aren't a new idea
they're used in the Swift as well as
some alternate python implementations
like Cinder and piston
to go back to the scaling table Immortal
objects work because we've transformed
rights to Shared data to read-only
accesses we've gone from modifying the
reference count fields of objects like
none true and false to only needing to
read that field to check if the object
is immortal
so why doesn't python already use
Immortal objects well for single
threaded code Immortal objects aren't a
clear when the cost of the extra Branch
Branch to check if the object is
Immortal is typically higher than the
work save by skipping the reference
count operation
for single threaded code at the language
Summit however back in April Eddie
Elizondo and Eric snow presented an
implementation of immortal objects with
smaller costs than previous efforts so
we might see mortal objects in C python
independent of any Gill changes
early on in this project I decided to
test out the implementation of Larry
Hastings Fibonacci Benchmark from the
galactomy project the benchmark's pretty
simple there's a function FIB that
calculates the M Fibonacci number and
it's called concurrently for multiple
threads the Fibonacci calculation is
deliberately slow it's mostly there to
do some work
I was running the program with an early
version of nogill python with eight
threads and I was pretty happy to see
the top command show all eight cores
being fully utilized
if you graph the performance results
they look something like this and I was
ready to call it a day and indeed this
would have been great if the chart
showed throughput versus the number of
threads but the y-axis here is actually
time taken even though the program was
using eight CPU cores those cores were
being used so inefficiently that there
wasn't a speed up in fact adding more
threads made things worse
here's the same data but inverted to
show throughput instead of time taken if
things were going well then eight
threads would be eight times faster than
a single thread but here eight threads
are actually only running at 25 percent
of the speed of a single thread
so what's going on
it's the same issue I mentioned
previously reference count contention
here is so bad the program didn't scale
at all and in this case reference count
contention wasn't solved by Immortal
objects
let's look at the python byte code I've
highlighted the two load Global byte
code operations these correspond to the
two recursive calls to FIB they load the
FIB function from the global dictionary
and push it to The Interpreter stack as
part of that operation they increment
the reference count of the FIB function
object
later when the function call is finished
the object is popped from the stack and
the reference count is decremented since
all the threads are calling the same
function they're also all concurrently
modifying that same reference count
field on the FIB function object
we could try making all functions
Immortal but that has a number of
downsides
functions don't necessarily live forever
in addition they hold a reference to the
Global's dictionary
so making functions Immortal would
prevent the global dictionary from being
freed which would in turn hold on to
Global variables unless those variables
were explicitly deleted
some programs and libraries depend on
running finalizers for Global variables
at exit
and making function objects Immortal
would prevent that from happening to the
reference chain from function objects to
the global dictionary to Global
variables
this project uses a variant of deferred
reference counting to address the
reference count contention on function
objects deferred reference counting
skips the reference counting operation
for objects as their pushed to and pop
from The Interpreter stack
other operations like assignment to a
dictionary list use the normal reference
counting Behavior
because we've skipped some reference
counting operations we can't free these
objects when the reference count reaches
zero instead they're only free during
the cyclic garbage collection
the garbage collector is modified to
inspect The Interpreter stack at the
start of a garbage collection cycle it
looks through all the objects on The
Interpreter stack adds back any missing
references that's the Deferred part of
deferred reference counting it then does
a normal garbage collection cycle and
finally removes the reference count that
it added in the first step
so deferred reference counting avoids
some reference counting operations but
it also delays deallocation
normally that could cause problems but
we only enable deferred reference
counting for some types of objects
module level functions methods and some
type objects
it turns out these objects would
typically only be deallocated during a
cyclic garbage collection cycle anyways
I mentioned before that function objects
have a reference to the global
dictionary
well the Global Security also has a
reference to functions defined at the
modular level functions in Python
naturally form site reference cycles and
there are similar reference cycles for
methods and type objects so deferred
reference counting on these objects
doesn't typically delay deallocation
compared to the normal behavior in C
python
here's the Fibonacci Benchmark again but
with deferred reference scanning enabled
the results are much better now and we
get a nearly eight times speed up with
eight threads
the no-gill project uses a combination
of these reference counting techniques
to achieve good single threaded
performance and avoid a lot of the
obstacles to multi-core scaling
most objects in no yell python use
biased reference counting they are
deallocated immediately when their
reference count goes to zero with a few
exceptions
few types of objects such as function
objects methods and some type objects
use deferred reference counting within
The Interpreter Loop Outside The
Interpreter Loop they're treated like
other objects and use bias reference
Counting they're only deallocated during
garbage collection Cycles
constants such as true false and none
are Immortal reference counting on these
objects is skipped everywhere both in
The Interpreter and in library code
they're never deallocated at least not
until The Interpreter shuts down
now that I've talked about reference
counting techniques I'd like to move on
to collection thread safety this is how
things like dictionaries lists and sets
handle concurrent accesses dictionaries
are particularly important because
they're widely used in Python including
for storing object attributes and Global
variables
like many previous attempts at removing
the guild the no-go project adds per
instance locks to collections like
dictionary and list
I'm going to talk a bit about the locks
used
the implementation is based on the locks
used in webkit the browser engine for
Safari the design and trade-offs are
described in detail by a Phil pislow in
a blog post called locking in webkit if
you're interested in how locks work I
highly recommend it it's one of my
favorite technical blog posts and if you
search locking in webkit it'll be the
first hit
I'm not going to describe the
implementation too much but I'll
describe some of the more important
attributes of the input of it first the
locks are small
they can be as small as two bits but due
to alignment requirements in C in nogo
python they typically require require
the same space as a pointer so eight
bytes in a 64-bit system that's still a
lot smaller than P thread mutex or C
plus 11 standard mutex which take 40 or
more bytes
the locks also only need to be
initialized to zero just like an integer
it doesn't require any memory allocation
it has fast uncontented access that's
really important because by far the most
common case is that only one thread
accesses a given collection at a time
finally it avoids thread starvation in
heavily contented locks by eventually
handing off the ownership of the lock to
the threads in the same order that they
attempt to choir at
all right that's it about the locks
themselves
one of the challenges with introducing
locks to collection types is that you
have to be careful to avoid introducing
lock ordering deadlocks
for example storing a value excuse me
destroying a key in some dictionary
might involve comparing that key to an
existing key already in the dictionary
for comparing it for equality in
particular
for string keys that comparison is
really simple but user-defined types can
override the equality operator and if
that user's code accesses either this
dictionary or some other dictionary
while implementing quality then we risk
deadlock by holding multiple locks while
another thread might attempt to acquire
those same locks in a different order
for dictionaries a reasonable solution
is to unlock the dictionary before
calling the equality operator and
re-lock it afterwards
essentially we make sure that a thread
can hold the lock for only a single
collection at any time and that's what
was implemented in this python excuse me
in this project for a while
but it
turns out there's a lot of places you
might want to call back that might call
back into Python and incidentally
acquire locks for example the pi deck
ref Mac Pro can call arbitrary code
through an object's finalizer
identifying all these places is doable
excuse me but it's tedious in error
prone and be really convenient if we
didn't have to be so careful about
unlocking and unlocking these locks
before calling back into python or
calling things like pi decref
notably the global interpreter log
doesn't have this issue
you just need to acquire the global
interpreter lock once and it's only
released in a few places usually
implicitly for the most part you don't
have to worry about lock ordering
Deadlocks with the global interpreter
log
fortunately we can make these locks
behave more like the Gill the basic idea
is to allow threads to implicitly
release locked collections
in places where the threads would have
normally released the Gill we don't do
this for all types of locks but instead
introduce a new internal API Pi begin
critical section and Pi n critical
section
Pi begin critical section locks the past
and lock and then pushes it to a stack
of active critical sections for the
current thread
subsequent cause to Pi begin critical
section also push onto that same stack
when the threads would have normally
released the Gill the threads instead
release all the locks for the active
critical sections and then Mark those
sections as inactive this includes times
when the thread is blocked trying to
acquire a lock held by a different
thread
in places where the thread would
normally reacquire the Gill it
reactivates the top most critical
critical section and locks the
corresponding lock however it doesn't
lock any previous critical sections
the pi n critical section releases the
lock for the topmost section and Pops it
from the stack
if there was a previous critical section
and it was inactivated it's now
reactivated and its lock is re-locked
the final Pi n critical section unlocks
and removes the last critical section
from the stack
the scheme avoids the risk of any lock
ordering Deadlocks to understand why
consider that a lock ordering deadlock
requires a thread to hold one lock let's
call it a
and be blocked while trying to acquire a
second law say B there's also has to be
another thread trying to acquire those
same locks but in a different order
with this API the moment a thread is
trying to acquire that second lock b it
will release its previously held locks
allowing other threads to proceed and
avoiding the deadlock
so since this avoids locket ordering
Deadlocks why isn't something like this
more widely used
well with this sort of scheme there's a
lot of places where the held box might
be implicitly released and that's not
something you really want in a general
locking API but it's fine here for
replacing the global interpreter lock
because the places where these locks
might have been implicitly released are
the exact same places where the Gill
could have been implicitly released
there's one additional bit to the
critical section API sometimes it's
useful to lock two collections at once
for example when extending a list with
the items of a dictionary it's useful to
lock both the list and the dictionary
the list because it's being modified in
the dictionary so that the extend
operation sees a consistent view of the
items in the dictionary
so there's one additional API that locks
two mutexes at once
lock-in collections works well for most
accesses but there's a few operations
where acquiring a lock would inhibit
scaling the most important is that when
accessing a single item in a dictionary
because things like globals and object
attributes are implemented using
dictionaries and a single dictionary may
be frequently accessed by many threads
just like we saw in the Fibonacci
example
the single element accesses for list and
dictionary are implemented without
acquiring the collection's lock
this is made more complicated by
reference Counting the acquiring the
accessing thread needs to increment the
reference Count Of The Returned object
but another thread might have
simultaneously modified the dictionary
and free that object
to handle this the fast lockless path
only handles the case where the
reference count isn't zero and where the
value is still in the collection if it
fails the operation falls back to a
slower path that retries the operation
after acquiring the collection's lock
normally this scheme wouldn't be safe
because when an object is freed its
memory including the reference count
field is invalid the scheme requires
cooperation with the memory allocator to
ensure that the reference count field
remains valid for the duration of this
axis even if the object's freed
that leads us to the memory allocator
python has a memory allocator called Pi
Malik it's optimized for small
allocations and it's used for allocating
python objects unfortunately it's not
thread safe
this project replaces Pi Malik with me
Malik a memory allocator written by Don
layan at Microsoft research
me Malik's performance is slightly
better than Pi Malik and it's thread
safe so it's like that Mima will end up
in Python independent of any Gill
changes and there's an outstanding PR
from Christian Hymes that implements me
Malik into C python
me Malek with some modifications is also
important for the lockless dictionary
and list accesses we just talked about
finally me Malik makes it easier to make
python cyclic garbage collector thread
safe
I'm going to describe how the garbage
collector Works in Python today and then
describe the modifications made when
removing the Gill and how using the
Malik helps
the first challenge with cyclic garbage
collection is that the mechanism used to
keep track of objects isn't thread safe
the current garbage collector relies on
a global linked list to find all python
objects that support cyclic garbage
collection
the linked list uses two fields in the
object's headers gcnext and GC previous
objects are inserted into the linked
list shortly after they're allocated and
removed from the linked list before
they're deallocated this poses a thread
safety issue because threads allocate
and free objects concurrently the list
also can't be made thread local because
the objects might be allocated in one
thread and deallocated on a different
thread
this project gets rid of the doubly
linked list although the GC next and GC
previous fields are still in use for now
instead of the linked list the garbage
collector uses me Malik to find all the
objects that support garbage collection
these objects are allocated from a
separate mimala keep than other data
The Collector scans each block in the
Heap to find objects unallocated blocks
and objects that aren't tracked by The
Collector have their least significant
bit and the first word set to zero
tracked objects have the least
significant bit set to 1.
the cyclic garbage collector can't run
safely when other threads are accessing
or modifying python objects the global
interpreter lock previously ensured this
but now the collector needs to pause all
of their python threads before running
python already had a mechanism for
requesting threads to handle
asynchronous signals and exceptions
which we've extended to handle requests
to pause for the garbage collector once
all other python threads are paused the
garbage collector runs the other threads
are resumed after the collector finishes
identifying unreachable objects
I want to talk a bit about compatibility
because a frequent concern with removing
the Gill is that it will break existing
python code in extensions for Pure
python code that is python code that
doesn't make use of the C API I don't
expect the code to require any changes
now that probably won't be a hundred
percent true but I think it's pretty
close to it importantly things like
things that looked Atomic with the Gill
like this dot append still look like
they're performed atomically due to per
collection locking
for C API extensions many don't require
any changes and those that do the
changes are pretty small I'll talk about
a few examples later the most common
issue is global or shared data in C
that's implicitly protected by the Gill
a less common issue is due to the use of
borrowed references for example Pi dick
get item and Pi list get item return
objects without increasing their
reference counts this can cause problems
if the dictionary or list is
concurrently modified
most uses of borrowed references aren't
an issue for example pi to get item is
frequently used to parse the keyword
arguments dictionary and that dictionary
is effectively private to the called
function it's not shared with other
threads
I'd like to give some examples from real
python packages that use the C API
scikit-learn is a python library for
machine learning that builds on top of
numpy and sci-fi
under the hood it's a mix of python
python and some C plus
thanks in large part to Olivia garcelle
scikit-learn now works without the Gill
and there's even a continuous build that
runs with no yield python I want to go
over the bugs we fixed while making
scikit-learn work without the Gill
getting all the psychic learning tests
to pass required fixing 10 issues of
these five were in the no guilt project
but unrelated to removing the Gill
the other five issues were related to
removing the Gill essentially thread
safety issues in these projects if you
ran them without the global interpreter
lock
one of these issues was in the
scikit-learn code base directly three of
them were in dependencies Two and numpy
and one in cython and the last one was
invis Tracer which isn't really a
dependency but a useful profiling tool
here's the bug in scikit-learn caused by
removing the Gill
this is an excerpt of some scython code
used to compute k-means when run without
the Gill and with openmp parallelism
enabled the operation would give an
incorrect result triggering test
failures the problem is that cython's
with Gill construct won't prevent
multiple threads from running at the
same time if you've already disabled the
Gill
the fix was pretty simple we just
replaced with Gill with a different lock
since the code is already using openmp
we use an openmp based lock
the actual PR that landed in
scikit-learn is a bit larger than this
because the same pattern is repeated a
few times in the file but this is the
essence of the fix
I'll only briefly go over the other
issues that cropped up when removing the
Gill
for numpy there were four total issues
but two of those were fixed before the
scikit learn effort
of the four issues three were issues due
to caches that were no longer thread
safe without the Gill some of those
caches could just be disabled when when
running with no yield python but one of
the caches had to be protected by a lock
one issue was due to the use of borrowed
references in numpy that was no longer
safe without the Gill that was fixed by
switching to an API that returned a new
reference instead
cython had an issue with locks allocated
from a pool that wasn't thread safe
without the Gill but it turns out those
locks weren't needed if Atomic
operations were available
finally this Tracer the profiling tool
had some internal State and C that
needed to be protected by a lock the
critical section API came to came in
handy there
the fixes for scikit-learn invis Tracer
have landed Upstream in those projects
but the changes to numpy and sci-fi
scython are still in Forks maintained by
me
overall the changes were relatively
small the scikit-learn test depended on
a total of 25 other python packages
other than the changes I mentioned here
those dependencies didn't require any
other changes
the other project I'd like to talk about
is work done by my colleagues at meta AI
on Hanabi Hanabi is a card game that's
been proposed as a benchmark problem in
AI
Hanabi is an interesting AI challenge
for a few reasons
first it's a Cooperative game two to
five players work together to place down
cards in numerical order
it's also an imperfect information game
you can see other players cards but you
can't see your own cards
and to play well you need to think about
your partner's behaviors and how they'll
respond to your actions and The Limited
information that you're allowed to share
my colleagues have developed agents Bots
that play Hanabi both with other Bots
and with people the Bots use artificial
neural networks to decide what actions
to take
and they're trained using reinforcement
learning techniques the code is partly
in Python using pytorch and numpy and
partly in C plus using pi bind 11.
here's a diagram of the system used to
train the Bob
the system simulates thousands of games
that's the section marked environment at
once using multiple threads
each thread is responsible for
simulating more than one game
the inference model and the training
model are the Bots neural networks the
inference model determines what action
the bot will take
in the simulated games the results of
those simulated games are fed into the
training model to improve the bot's
behaviors
every so often the training model is
copied back to the inference model
the Nabi system was built with vanilla
Python and with the global interpreter
locked in mind the worker threads and
inference Loops have to avoid running
python code
only the training Loop and the training
model run the python interpreter
this means that many pieces of code had
to be written in C plus or like the
inference model written in a subset of
python called torch script that
serialized your representation that can
be executed from C plus without invoking
the python interpreter
having so many components in C plus plus
made it harder to explore new research
ideas my colleague henyon implemented a
version of the system designed for
running without the Gill
most of the components were moved to
python including the worker threads the
inference model
and um
and the logic for each player the
environment that's the component that
implemented the rules of the game stayed
in c plus because there isn't a
compelling reason to move it to python
the research ideas don't involve
changing the rules of Hanabi as I
mentioned before the project uses numpy
pytorch and Pi bind 11. those projects
were already patched to work without the
Gill although we found and fixed another
issue with the pipeline 11 patch in the
course of this work
I'd like to show the performance of the
system and the steps we took to optimize
it first here's a chart showing the
performance of the new mostly python
system with the global interpreter lock
the x-axis shows the number of worker
threads and the y-axis shows the number
of games simulated per second
the Gill is pretty clearly a bottleneck
here using more than one worker thread
doesn't improve performance
here's the performance once the Gill is
removed now adding more worker threads
improves performance at least up to a
bit this only shows up to eight threads
but the computer it's running on has up
to four has 40 Hardware cores this is
the same system no Gill but with even
more worker threads up to 80 instead of
only up to eight we hit a bottleneck
pretty quickly increasing the number of
worker threads Beyond 10 didn't improve
performance running with more worker
threads actually hurt performance
to investigate this I use Linux perf
tools and GDB
perf top showed that the majority of CPU
time was spent trying to acquire a lock
but didn't give much information beyond
that GDB narrowed the issue further
at any given point most of the threads
were stuck trying to acquire at the same
lock
this is a lock I added to our patched
version of Pi by an 11 to make it thread
safe
Pi bind maintains an internal hash table
called registered instances that Maps C
plus plus pointers to their
corresponding python wrappers this is
done so that if you run this that if you
return the same C plus object multiple
times you always get back the same
python wrapper object the lock I added
to protect the hash table was the source
of the bottleneck
there are a lot of techniques for
implementing concurrent hash tables but
one of the simplest is to split the
table into multiple pieces each a hash
table with its own lock the key in this
case the C plus pointer is used both to
determine which Subhash table to use and
to index into it
this works surprisingly well and was
easy to implement the turquoise bars
show the performance after splitting up
the registered instances table this new
system can simulate nearly 1200 games
per second with 60 workers which is
about a 20 time speed up compared to if
we ran this program with a global
interpreter lock enabled
I suspect there's still opportunities to
further improve scaling but we think
this system has performance comparable
to the original C plus heavy system
and having more of the components in
Python made it much easier to explore
new research ideas
you can try out the no-gil version of
python yourself both URLs here go to the
same GitHub page
the easiest way to install it is a pi
end a python version management tool for
Linux and Mac there's also a Docker
image or you can build no Guild python
from Source if you prefer
you can you can pip install most
packages including many scientific
Computing libraries please let me know
if something doesn't work by filing an
issue on the Project's GitHub page
in the next month or so I'll be working
on a python enhancement proposal or pep
proposing to remove the global
interpreter lock from a future version
of python using these projects using the
ideas from this project
to help address compatibility issues
I'll propose placing the Gill changes
behind a compiler flag
so that the default build will still
have the Gill enabled
I expect this to take some time but in
the meantime I'd appreciate your
feedback on the project either on GitHub
or elsewhere and if you're interested in
efficient multi-threaded python programs
please try out nogil python the